>> Laura: GETTING THE RUN AWAY
AT DOMINICK RUNAROUND FROM THE
FBI AND DOJ, DEVIN NUNES WENT
STRAIGHT TO THE DIRECTOR
DAN COATS TODAY.
HE GAVE THE AGENCY AT 5:00 A.M.
DEADLINE TO TURN OVER KEY
DOCUMENTS IN THE RUSSIA AND
HILLARY CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
>> I WOULD SAY WE CLEANED UP
MOST OF WHAT WAS ON THE TABLE
EXCEPT FOR THE MOST IMPORTANT
PIECE.
DID YOU OR DID YOU NOT RUN
INFORMANTS INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, ESPECIALLY BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION EVEN BEGAN.
VERY SIMPLE QUESTION, IT
DESERVES A VERY SIMPLE ANSWER.
>> Laura: THE FBI RESPONDED
LATE TONIGHT SAYING, THEY HAVE
CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS JOINS
SO YOU HAVE THE DOCUMENTS YOU
ARE ENTITLED TO?
>> THE ONE GOOD THING THAT THE
FBI AND DOJ IS GOOD AT IS
CREATIVE WRITING.
ANY TIME YOU WOULD SUGGEST THAT
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
DELIVERED, AS WE SPEAK RIGHT
NOW, WE HAVE A VALID SUBPOENA
THAT HAS NOT BEEN REALLY
RESPONDED TO APPROPRIATELY, AND
IT'S 97 DAYS AND TICKING.
SO FOR THEM TO SUGGEST THAT WE
>> Laura: >> Laura: KEVN
>> Laura: >> Laura: KEVK
>> Laura: >> Laura: KEVE
>> Laura: >> Laura: KEVN
>> Laura: >> Laura: KEVM
>> Laura: >> Laura: KEVT
>> Laura: >> Laura: KEV.
TELL US ABOUT KEVIN KLEINSMITH.
WE NEED OUR OWN DECK OF CARDS.
JUST TO IDENTIFY, NOT FOR
ANYTHING DIFFERENT, JUST TO
IDENTIFY THEM.
IT'S LIKE THE LOVE BOAT HERE.
>> YOU HAVE SALLY MOYER, YOU
HAVE ALL THESE DIFFERENT
INDIVIDUALS.
THERE IS ONE COMMON THEME AND
IT'S CALLED BIAS.
BIAS AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT.
FBI ATTORNEY, ATTORNEY NUMBER
TWO IS WHAT WE BELIEVE.
>> Laura: IN THE IG REPORT.
>> AND CHUCK ROSS, AND THE IG
HAS NOT CONFIRMED THAT BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE SUSPECT.
CHUCK ROSS DID SOME GREAT
REPORTING TODAY AND SAID THAT HE
WAS THE ONE INTERVIEWING
PAPADOPOULOS.
SO HERE YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS
IT'S EXTREMELY TROUBLING.
>> NOW KLEINSMITH, LIKE MOYER,
AS EVIDENCING BIAS THROUGH
VARIOUS TEXT MESSAGES THAT WERE
RELEASED.
>> A LOT OF TEXT MESSAGES.
THAT PETER STRZOK WAS INVOLVED
WITH.
SO IT'S ALL OF THEM COMING
TOGETHER WITH NOT ONE, NOT TO,
BUT FIVE PEOPLE THAT WERE BIASED
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT AND THEY
INITIATED THE INVESTIGATION.
SO HERE'S THE INTERESTING THING.
WHAT WE'VE GOT TO DO AS A
COUNTRY'S BECOME TRANSPARENT.
GIVE US THE DOCUMENT, LET US PUT
THE COVER-UP.
>> Laura: JEFF SESSIONS WAS ON
OUR SHOW LAST WEEK AND --
>> HE RECUSED HIMSELF BUT HE HAS
REALLY RECUSED HIMSELF OF ANY
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
SO ROD ROSENSTEIN KNOWS BETTER.
HE REALLY DOES KNOW BETTER AND
THE BUCK STOPS WITH HIM.
LAURA.
THIS WEEK ON THE HOUSE FLOOR,
WHERE WE COMPEL THEM TO TURN
OVER THOSE DOCUMENTS.
>> Laura: JUST SO PEOPLE KNOW,
KLEINSMITH IS THE ONE WHO WROTE
"VIVA LA RESISTANCE" ."
>> IF HE IS INDEED.
>> THEY ARE NOT PART OF THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE DIVISION.
>> Laura: WHICH THEY ARE AT
UNDERCOVER OPERATION AND
CERTAINLY WASN'T HERE.
>> Laura: NEWS TONIGHT THAT
ERIC PRINCE'S COMPUTERS HAVE
BEEN SEIZED AND SO FORTH.
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT?
FORMER BLACKWATER CEO.
>> SO WHAT YOU SEE IS BOB
DOCUMENTS FROM DONALD TRUMP IN
90 DAYS AND YET THEY CAN'T TURN
OVER 50,000 DOCUMENTS TO
CONGRESS IN NINE MONTHS, THAT'S
A PROBLEM.
>> Laura: WHAT'S NEXT FOR
NUNEZ AFTER THE 5:00 P.M.
DEADLINE?
>> I THINK THE NEXT THING IS
FLOOR ACTION FOR ALL OF US.
>> Laura: RYAN WILL DO THAT?
>> WHILE HE MADE A PROMISE TO US
WOULD SEEP FLOOR ACTION THIS
FEES AMOUNT OF HIS WORD, HE WILL